hi my name is Daniel Pham and welcome to
this week in Android development on
Monday December 17 2013 last week Todd
and Wolf hosted an awesome episode of
game on showing off the new open-source
physics engine liquid fun today nas mo
and Laura Klein talked about lean UX and
Todd returned for less than 2 point 0 in
his dead bite series play games for
iowa's look for the next episode the
drop later this week in the latest app
news google Santa tracker has launched
yay with three built-in games and
chromecast integration we also heard
that you like managing your devices so
we gave you the ability to manage your
devices from your device with Android
device manager last but not least the
google play games plugin for unity was
launched head on over to github for
everything you need that's all for this
week in Android development will be
going on holiday for a few weeks so
we'll see you next year I'm Daniel Pham
you are my fire the one desire believe
me when I say I want it that way